el presidente chileno Gabriel Boris
realizó su segunda Cuenta pública en lo
que fue el discurso más largo de la
historia desde el retorno a la
democracia y en la que evaluó las
consecuciones de su año y casi tres
meses de mandato Como por ejemplo la
reducción de la jornada laboral a 40
horas semanales el incremento
significativo del salario mínimo la
persecución a los deudores de alimentos
aquellas personas que no pagan los
alimentos de sus hijos a sus exparejas y
también el royalti minero para el futuro
trazó tres líneas derechos sociales en
las que destacan medidas como tratar de
lograr la reducción de un 40% de las
listas de espera en la salud pública o
la tratar de lograr la equidad en los
salarios entre hombres y mujeres otra
línea fue la seguridad en la que destacó
el uso de tecnología para perseguir el
crimen organizado pero también aspectos
como restricciones a los narcos
funerales o los narco mausoleos que se
construyen en el país también última
línea de desarrollo sostenible en la que
destacaron aspectos estratégicos de la
economía del país como el litio las
energías limpias o el hidrógeno verde el
presidente hizo un gran llamado a la
unidad para lograr una nueva reforma
tributaria con la que financiar muchas
de las reformas sociales prometidas por
su gobierno y también finalmente lograr
Y tratar de alcanzar al acuerdos para
que los chilenos puedan tener pensiones
mucho más altas de las que perciben en
la actualidad una de las demandas de más
larga Data de la ciudadanía chilena